[Music]
you
hello so
to the second section of memory as they
discussed in the last class we saw what
is memory what is the need for it and
what type of 20 process this is we also
discussed about model model of memory
what the model model talks about or how
memory is multi-store in a single store
kind of a concept so in the single store
memory was discussed as processes which
work or which use a single store for
storing but different processes define
different kinds of memories whereas in
the multiple store model there are
different stores and different processes
related to each store and that is how
the model is defined we also looked at
the first unit or the first part of the
model model that we discussed in the
last class and that was paused the
sensory memory so we looked at what is
sensory memory what is the different
aspects of sensory memory different
requirements of it and how does it work
we looked at two basic types of special
sensory memories these are the visual
memory and the auditory sensory memory
now in today's class what we are trying
to finish is short-term memory so what
is short-term memory now looking back at
the definition of the model model
memory is a three part system and it's
also proposed by at internship and
attention shipments model of memory the
first part of which is sensory memory
and when an information is processed
from sensory memory using attentional
filters or intentional filters
information from sensory memory is
passed on to something called the
short-term memory
now the short-term memory store is
basically thought of as a store which
has limited capacity but it can store
information for longer
nine longer than the duration which is
available the durability of time which
is available for the short-term store or
the STS also the main difference between
the short-term memory and the sensory
register the sensory store is the amount
of information which can be stored so
basically a large amount of information
is what the sensory register holds
whereas the short-term store can hold
only limited information so let's
continue our this lecture on short-term
store and look at some of the properties
of the short-term memory so starting
with the definition of what it really
means
short-term memory when people mostly
talk about is a type of memory which
people use for temporary holding
information think of a scenario like
this you're on a call talking to someone
and within the call itself number is
given to you by the caller the person
who's speaking to you gives you a number
to dial to now imagine a situation where
you have nothing at your hand to write
this number down so what do you do how
do you remember this number or how do
you make sure that the number telephone
number which has been passed on to you
from the collar stays with you till the
call ends the most likely scenario or
the most likely thing that most people
do is locally rehearse this number and
so this number till the point of time
that you are vocally rehearsing it stays
with you if you stop rehearsal then this
number goes away and this particular
temporary store where this telephone
number or the number given to you by the
collar stays is what is called the
short-term store so here mostly if not
rehearsed most information which is
passed on from the Census register stays
for no longer than a second one or two
seconds so that's the timeframe which is
there and as we saw a time frame for
which the information stores on to or
stays on to the sensor
history's about 100 250 milliseconds so
basically the in short-term store is a
temporary store which holds on to
information little information but for a
longer duration of time now as far as
the definition goes short-term our
primary inactive stores it is the
capacity of holding small informations
for some limited period of time
now the question again comes to us is
what is the capacity of this store as we
saw the capacity of the other store
which was the short-term store was huge
it has a huge capacity in taking a lot
of information but then what is the
capacity of the short-term store also we
talked about processes which are active
during or which are inbuilt to these
stores so one of the processes which
helps in passing information from the
short-term store to the short-term
memory is called the attentional
processes so basically attention is that
process which takes in information from
the short-term store and depending on
people's motivation and intentions and
the requirement of the task move
information moves on to a short-term
store to a short-term memory
so as concerning the capacity of the
short-term store a paper was written by
Sperling I'm sorry George Miller in 1956
and where he defines the store to be
having a capacity of seven plus or minus
two chunks of item
now when I say seven plus or minus two
chunks of item what I am specifically
trying to tell you here is that chunk is
a word and it's it's it's a conceptual
word so seven plus or minus two chunks
doesn't mean that you have to have nine
or five items into it but a chunks of an
item so basically let's go ahead and
define water chunk is so chunk is a
process or chunking is a process where
meaningful units or meaningful materials
which are similar to each other are
clubbed together are categorized
together we'll look into this in the
chapter of categorization how does this
process happen but for now chunking is a
process of basically putting into a
similar mean items which are
conceptually or meaningfully similar in
nature for example letters conformer
chunk or digits can form a chunk and
certain other for example visual stimuli
scan from a chunk and that kind of thing
is junking so the capacity which has
been defined by georges milies paper is
called 7 plus or minus 2 that is the
maximum capacity of information which
can be stored into the short-term memory
now the thing is this is also called the
magical number and very recent studies
my nicer demonstrates that it is not
seven plus or minus two items but it is
rather four plus or minus two items that
is the capacity of the short-term store
so one thing is the capacity the next
thing to like example of how chunking
really works so if I show you this
string which is at the top of this
particular slide and if I ask you to
remember this if I show this string to
you for let's say a hundred millisecond
or for one second and then I ask you
back to relate back what are the number
of things that you are seeing or what
are the number of letters that you are
seeing here it becomes a difficult job
so I'll demonstrate what chunking is
what chunking really does is to make
meaningful sentences or Club meaningful
sentences together so one way to
remember this whole string is to
understand the fact that this string has
acronyms from the famous detective
agencies or basically security agencies
of the world so what I do is if I can
break into three chunks FBI is one
agency NSA is another agency
as an agency CBI is an agency CIA is an
agency mi5 is an agency and B and D is
an agency so these basically can be
chunked into smaller chunks the meaning
of the chunk or the meaning of the bin
which holds these chunks together is
security agencies and that way you will
be able to remember this whole number of
digits or this whole string of so
this is basically what is the process of
chunking then another thing that we want
to know is how are things coded into the
STM nitrous area explicit to us that
coding in the short-term store was
dependent on modality so different
modalities had different codes in the
short-term store so is it also true for
our SDM what is the way in which
information is coded into the SDM that
is an interesting thing to be looked at
now the coding in STM generally happens
to be in terms of the caustic feature or
in terms of the caustic way so
information mostly are held on to your
STM in an a caustic trace which
basically means that this sub vocal
rehearsal that we are talking about in
our earlier example where we were
looking at how this study this number
was given to you by your friend over a
telephone and so you needed needed to
dial this number what you tend to do is
mentally rehearse it and so when you are
mentally rehearsing it you are doing a a
caustic rehearsal now just to prove in
the fact that it is a caustic trace that
is the way of how items are coded or how
items are stored on to the short-term
store or short-term memory koenraad 1964
he conducted a famous experiment and so
what his experiment was he gave people
some letters to remember and a string of
letters to remember
later on ask them to remember these
letters Pat for example Kay's GC or TBC
kind of thing and what he found out from
the remembrance that when people try to
remember these letters back what he
found out that people confused or
committed errors by retrieving or in in
retrieval by those letters which sounded
similar together
so basically letters which sounded
similar or which appeared similar they
created more confusions or more errors
then for those letter strings in which
letters were not similar together for
example in terms of when a visual
presentation of letters weighed on so to
presentation of these letters were done
in one case KGC kind of a thing was
given to people and in in and we in an
auditory manner and or through an
auditory stimulus in the other version
of the experiment this KGC was shown to
people and so when this kind of a
stimulus was shown to people it was that
people made more confusions when
auditory testing was done and what
happened here is that K the K or the G
confused more with C people made more
confusions with C whereas in terms of in
terms of the visual
people didn't can confuse with the
letters G and C so it is basically the
caustic code or it is basically the
acoustics are the four names the basic
speech sound which made the confusion
and that led to the idea that it is
coding which happens in the STM is
mostly in the caustic and form Nate in
1988 he found that people use a caustic
code dominantly for STM storage and
recall so basically people do some kind
of a sub vocal rehearsal and it is not
mental images it is not imagery that
people make off items in the STM people
generally
make an acrostic trees or an acrostic
image I would say so let's not use the
word images or in a caustic trace of any
information which has to be put into STM
and and basically then remember it that
way now the question then which is in
front of us right now is what is the
retention duration and how does
forgetting take place in STM not to to
the way in which the attention is done
in STM or how items are retained in STM
and what is the way in which forgetting
takes place in STM several experiments
fact discussed and so what I will try
and do at present is show you two
different versions of the experiment in
first version which is called the Brown
and Peterson task will see that decay
has been named as the reason for
forgetting whereas in the fog and norman
task i will try and show you the same
explanations the same results from the
walk from the peters peterson and brown
experiment or how it is explained in
terms of interference so basically there
are several theories of how items get
moved out or items are forgotten and so
there are two popular theories of it one
is the decay theory which basically goes
ahead and says that items which are not
used for a longer period of time they
decay so they what happens is that they
trace the memory traces erased and they
got they get decayed or without use in
the theory of not you says that they
slowly be there away with time so that
raised itself disappears another theory
of forgetting is the interference theory
which says that if items of similar
nature they come in contact with each
other or if one item is presented in the
second item which is similar in nature
to the first item is presented alongside
then one eye both the items will compete
with each other and they will
interference so basically in the next
section in long-term memory when we will
discuss we will also discuss on to the
interference phenomena but now these are
the two modes of forgetting so what
people were wondering is what is the
nature of forgetting or how things are
forgotten in to esteem and how they are
stored so let's then look at these
experiments one by one the first
experiment is called the Brown and
Peterson task so what is the task all
about and so this this experiment was
done by Brown and Peterson in 1959 so
what is the experiment all about now in
the drawing Peterson experiments a very
experiment to look at a digit string was
presented to people so digit string like
this was presented to people and what
they had to do this digit strings were
generally a try again a three letter
word or three letter trigram a triangle
is basically a three letter word which
doesn't make sense because if you have
sensible word here then the chances of
you recalling it will be better because
it makes meaning and so a trigram is
used and basically the start starting
point of tri gang of or who started the
use of Trigon was basically event
because what he did was he created three
letter words of the format CVC which is
the consonant vowel consonant format and
so in CVC he combined three words
together or three letters of the English
language together so that they don't
make any meaning for example K and C or
Q K T now these words don't make meaning
and so they're combined together and
this is what a diagram is so in this
particular experiment an arrangement was
done in which people were shown this
kind of try GAMP and so after they were
shown this try again they were asked to
come back this trying m to memory so
basically someone is shown this dragon
and they're asked to commit this to
memory later on they were said to count
back from 1,000 increase so the first
really
nine nine let's say seven and then the
next will be nine nine seven minus three
so we'll be nine nine four and so on and
so forth so keep on counting like this
so our task was introduced so the the
working of the task is that I distract
this kind of heart like I was introduced
people were made to commit this to
memory to sub vocally remember it so we
were given this task and the sub
Oakleigh remember it and later on a
delay destructor tasks like this was
given it is called the end back counting
task here what you need to do is that
you have to count back in digits of
three this kind of a thing and keep on
counting now people were stopped at
several points of time starting from
twenty seconds delay so within the first
twenty second they were worse so people
remember this task and they started
counting back and after the first twenty
second they were stopped and asked to
relay it back this this try again so
this is called the recoil diagram phrase
in which after the first twenty second
people were asked to stop so within this
twenty second people are counting back
now one thing is that that this counting
back tasks then background and back
counting tasks as it is called this
requires a huge amount of short-term
memory it requires a huge amount of
attention and so most attentional
resources will be diverted to it and so
chances of the any chance of people to
basically subvocal rehearse this this
particular thing is not possible it's
not at all possible in this task and so
this was to demonstrate the fact that
this khr or this recall was basically do
to indicate now people were stopped at
two seconds time
after the counting start started so they
were made to recall the tagging after
two seconds four seconds six seconds
till twenty seconds so after every two
seconds they were made to stop this
counting task and recall back the
diagram what really happened what is the
result of this experiment the result of
this experiment showed that after 18
seconds so this is what the result looks
like if you look into it initially what
happened is this is the relative
accuracy which is there in the recall
interval of time so what the first thing
that shows or that is evident from this
particular result is that at 18 seconds
the curve becomes a sort of a simple tat
and so which basically means that to the
recall accuracy doesn't fall anymore so
the curve runs parallel to this but if
you look into it for the first three
seconds there is a maximum fall of
accuracy so this is the portion if I
draw this then this is the kind of
portion which is then immediately there
is an accuracy so just let's say half a
second the accuracy is almost 1 which
means that people are almost highly
accurate 80% accurate and recalling the
or more than 85% accurate and recalling
the trigram back but then as you proceed
in time by the fur by the first third
second by the third second of still the
start of that accounting task people
almost lose the accuracy by or the
accuracy drops down by 42 to 43 percent
by the next 6 second it drops to almost
let's say around 35% and then similarly
it keeps on dropping till it becomes
stable at 18 second and this idea gave
or this task gave two prominent result 1
that decay is the reason for the
forgetting since
the task was so heavy the working memory
task which was used was for heavy what
happened is people didn't get time to
repeat and so the trace of memory trace
of this task went on decreasing till it
reached a very low level which is nearly
0.1 here the point one chances of
accuracy here after 18 second also
another important thing that was
demonstrated here was that the time
period for which any item get stored on
to the short term store and the time
period which was determined through
their experiments by Brown Peterson was
eighteen to twenty second this is the
time period through which an item will
be in your short-term memory if not
rehearsed and after twenty second a
rehearsal doesn't happen then most items
from the short-term memory will go away
and so the duration of the short-term
memory from this experiment is twenty
second now Brown and Peterson task which
explains decay as the reason for the
delay can also be explained by the walk
and norman task but before that let's
look at the results from broaden
Peterson tasks the study interpreted
that freely talk recall occurs during
the decay of due to the key of memory
traces and though within the first
twenty second no another group is said
that vagan norman tried to explain this
result in terms of interference and so
what they said is that they challenged
the decayed here we are forgetting in
memory and proposed a different
mechanism which is called interference
so interference as I explained to you is
a phenomena in which what happens is
that two items which are similar in
nature they compete with each other and
so they block the recall of one item or
the important thing two
remember is that they have to be two
tasks have to be similar in nature and
they have to be competing if they're not
competing if people are not focusing on
both the task then the interference
phenomena will not happen so basically
then the fearest theory says that some
information displaces another
information making the farmer hard to
retrieve as the second item competes
with the first item and since they are
similar in nature
people confuse and the second item is
pushed out or interfered out from the
memory so an explanation of the same
Brandon Peterson task or Varga Norman's
interpretation of what happens in terms
of forgetting and time delay in SDM
another task was design which is called
the probe digit task for explaining the
interference phenomena or interference
for getting from short-term memory now
what was the task it's a very easy task
to look at so it's a 16-digit number
task so a 16 digit is presented to you
at one go so you have things like 2 4 6
8 4 6 3 4 3 6 8 9 4 3 4 2 3 4 5 6 so
this kind of a setup is presented to you
so one example is given here the last
digit now this digit then serves as a
cue so or digit like this
a string like this is presented to
people and what they have to do is to
first recognize the last digit and this
serves the cue now what is the task the
task is to basically go ahead and name
the letter which preceded the first
occurrence of the last word here what do
I mean by this what I mean by this is
that this six which is the last digit in
this string this serves as a cue and so
that is the first occurrence of this the
first occurrence of this is here and so
the letter B precedes the first
occurrence of the six is four and so
what people had to say is four was the
correct answer so you had two people
have two last digit in the number is a
cue for the participant a report a
number that the
number that first came after the first
occurrence the queue in the number and
so that is what it is and so far is the
answer here so this is the task a 16
digit number is presented you have to
remember the last digit remember the
first occurrence of the last digit and
remember the number which preceded the
first office of the last digit now there
are two versions of this task in the
first version letters represented very
fast so either very quickly at the rate
of four digit per second so this whole
string was presented at the rate of four
digit for a second and so people had to
then go ahead and so first the string
was presented and then the string was
presented in a manner in that four
digits very quickly were presented to
people and then from the last one so for
for the sixteenths for presentation are
there four digits presented together
into four different times makes it 16 so
you have to last remember the last one
remember the last digit and then
remember where the first occurrence or
the last digit on the fourth panel was
there and then go ahead and tell me
the first number which occurred in the
the first occurrence of the last cue and
or there was another presentation which
was one digit for a second so 16 seconds
16 repetitions rather than here four
repetitions were done with four digits
or a sixteen repetition one number at a
time was presented people who remember
asked to do the task no walk in Norman
the reason that if decay cost forgetting
in STM then participants receiving a
slow rate of presentation should not be
able should not be as good at recalling
digits from early in the number which
basically means that if the first
occurrence of the last digit in the 16
digit string comes in the first half or
towards the middle of the list then
people should not be able to remember
this but this is not what happened
keeping an Underwood they found that
forgetting in the brown Peterson tasks
doesn't happen until after few trials so
what happens is this is not the answer
they found they found that they have a
similar kind of
forgetting which was then but then if
words they're similar if if DK is the
reason then this kind of answer should
come but this is not what they found
they found that quite similar kind of
forgetting into both the versions of the
task and so now this Kapil and Underwood
they found that forgetting in the brown
and Peterson toss doesn't happen until a
few trials had happened they suggested
is overtime proactive interference
brings up so what happens is that well
in in in the four into four kind of a
set what happens is due to proactive
interference if they disappear in the
later half if the first presentation of
the cue happen in the later half
forgetting was more but if the
presentation was in the earlier half
forgetting was less and so this kind of
an result was what was form from the
worgen Norman which basically suggests
that interference is the reason for
forgetting so this is how the task looks
like this is 16-digit task this is the
first occurrence of it and this is what
you tend to remember and this is what
affects our presentation rate versus
number of interfering item is looked at
so if four items are there then you tend
to have so if you look here the number
of interfering items are five if this is
there at four second pour the 1 second
end the four second presentations are
almost similar in terms of relative
accuracy but then if the number of
digits interfering various number of
interfering items are more which means
that the number of letters which are
presented or number of letters which
precede the first occurrence of the Q so
if my Q is like this let's say sixteen
digit and so four digits so a block of
four into four what happens is if my Q
the first occurrence of Q falls here
somewhere then the chances of forgetting
the accuracy of forget will go down in
the for presentation group but not in
the one presentation group but then what
happens is if I am presenting it in one
one word at a time there won't be any
interference and so
there will be no forgetting at all here
and so this basically is a concrete
example to basically go ahead and say
that with interferences the reason for
forgetting and so this graph in itself
explains that a four words per second is
there and how it relates to number of
interfering items is the number of
interfering item is five this is where
both the list matches but as it goes to
seven the one word has lower accuracy
then the forward items and this happens
because in the one word the interference
will be more since one words are
presented one after another and so there
will be a lot of interference but in
this there are only four presentations
of the interference will be less then
the question is is forgetting from STM
rdk or interference related phenomena
now it's a badly first question why
because it rules are the possibility for
lost by both the phenomena and so broad
Baddeley said in 1990 I used that phrase
decay does occur from STM alpha and we
also propose that decay does occur in
fact an essential to avoid catastrophic
throw at proactive interferences
basically both these people go ahead and
say that it is not one over the other
kind of a thing both the factors decay
an interference they go ahead and then
they basically relate to each other to
actually go ahead and show that this
kind of interference has happened or
both the items are responsible for the
interference now these are authors
believe that information must be updated
frequently in memory its current value
decays to prevent interference with the
previous values so another interesting
thing that can be that was looked at is
that if interference is there is a
reason why forgetting happens in
short-term memory phenomena which is
called the release from proactive
interference now as as we saw in the
worgen normal study it was basically
proactive interference which was the
reason why forgetting happened and
forgetting happen in the one word item
very clear explanation what happens is
since
is one word presentation so there will
be 16 occurrences of it and so more
number of interferences but in the for
white a word items or for red
presentation there are only four
different presentations which are there
and so interferences are unless the
proactive interference is the lesson
number and so what we have here an
interesting thing that we have here is
that a phenomena called proactive
release now what is proactive release so
we concern born an experiment was done
by weekends and born in 1963 and what
these people said is that the phenomena
of proactive release from proactive
interference should be evident if
interference is the reason for
forgetting in the brown Peters and tasks
now what this phenomena really says is
that if interference happens because
similar items are presented so if items
are different items are presented to
people then what would happen is they
would show interference or the
performance would increase and that is
what exactly happen so what these people
showed that if similar type of items was
used in Brown and Peterson task so if
letters only may use then people had
lower higher forgetting rate and that
because it was due to interference but
then if on one particular expects
presentation you had letters everywhere
as well as digits coming in so you have
a number and a 16 digit number where you
have letters and digits fill in to it
and so you have to tell me the last
occurrence of either a letter in a digit
so the display would look like something
like 1 to 4 is C's 6 4 3 D K kind of a
thing and let's say e is the last year
and so or a is the last year and so you
have to tell me then the digit 4 which
comes out to the first occurrence of the
letter a in this case the forgetting was
known to
unless the reason given was released
from proactive interference which means
that when items were switched
so here what happened is items were
switched and so some items were letters
and some items were numbers in this case
the proactive interference is well less
and so in those cases where you have to
remember a letter a digit after letter
in those cases the interferences were
less but if let's say if the last word
here is not K let's say if it is 4 and
people have to remember the number which
comes or that the item which comes after
the first occurrence of 4 which is 2 now
since 2 and 4 are both digits and so
they will create more proactive
interference but if let's say the last
word is here a or let's say that this is
4 and a comes in before 4 in this case
is a is remembered more so if the word
which appears after the first occurrence
of the Q is a different word it's not
the same as the one which is the Q when
productive interferences will be very
less because for the phenomena which is
called the release from proactive
interference so how is information
retrieved from short-term memory that's
another thing to be looked at and
interesting so we looked at how it is
stored what is the manner in which
forgetting happens what is the time and
what is the duration for which an item
it stays in STM and what is the kind of
coding which happens in SDM
so in this particular next step we look
into how is information retrieved from
SDM what is the way in it so Saul
Steinberg he designed in explained to
looked at how items are actually
retrieved back from SDM and what did he
find
so what was his task like his task was
search for information in serial or
parallel form so he had people look at a
display like this where seven or few
letters where so seven or few letters
were given to people to be kept in the
memory bank to be remembered into
memory and then later on a cue was
presented to people so let's say we have
seven or few letters which people have
to remember so these letters are a B K T
kind of a thing and then they are
presented with C people are presented we
see and what they have to look at is to
find out whether this C is presented
here or not and so they have to hold
this in memory and then later on verify
this cue or this probe cue whether it is
present here or not and then so from his
experiments he came up with a very
interesting example or a very
interesting proposal and what is this
proposal he conducted this kind of an
experiment and found some interesting
results what was it first something
called parallel search happened so when
comparison of probe is done with all
items stored in the STM at the same time
then it is something called parallel
search so if C is searched with every of
this item every one of this item it is a
parallel search but when us for
comparison or the probe is done with all
items stored in the STM one at a time it
is called a serial search so the
question here was this kind of two
searches could be the result result of
an experiment now if you remember the
first lecture we talked about something
called structure process trade-off and
we saw how stalls are strong words the
same experiment is described here how
solid Starnberg went ahead and described
this whole process of serial versus
parallel search and he gave reasons for
what really happens how the structure
and the process compensate for each
other and is the same thing now within
the serial search Steinberg
basically proposed that there are two
versions of the serial search the one is
called the self terminating search in
which what happens is as soon as so this
C will be searched with a or compared
with a if it is not a match this C will
again go into searching with B which is
the next letter so this is my letter
items which is in the memory set and
since my probe goes ahead and
matches I have seen here and when as
soon as the sea matches with this a self
termination happens so the list is not
further search doc although the list has
seven items as soon as the sea is there
here I ever know so the match or the
matching proceeds to be if it is not
match here it will proceed here but as
soon as the match is there a seraph
termination will happen a sort of
termination will take place but in
another form of the search which is
called the exhaustive search
what Strandberg says is that no matter
the fact that this sea is matched here
this C is again matched to the next item
which could be a B or which could be
another C so the whole number of items
which are there in the memory set will
be searched one after another with a
probe and that is what is called a
serial exhaustive search and what
Sternberg argued is that the way in
which short-term memory starts is
basically the serial exhaustive search
so no matter if even if you get a clear
search first of all there are no
parallel searches in STM there are
always serial searches and even if the
serial search is done it is not a self
terminating search even if a match is
found to the probe even if some item
matches the item that you're looking for
in your SDM the search will continue
till the end of the list this is because
the exhaustive search takes place and
the one probable reason could be the
fact that multiple copies of the item
would be there and so the requirement of
that makes you to do something called
the exhaustive serial exhaustive search
and so to test so a review done by hunt
1978 found that people of all sorts
showed results consistent with the idea
that retrieval from STM uses serial
exhaustive search
although the search rate changes with
the group now derozen take a 1976
demonstrated that with certain stimuli
people apparently do such STM in a
parallel way so basically D Rosa came up
with an experiment to show that the both
the serial as
the parallel search does happen in STM
and so the designed sequence are kind of
a stimuli to test that and the results
of their study was so let's look at the
stimuli that they use for their
experiment so in their experiment they
gave a situation like this stimulus like
this now if you look at the stimulus
there are one two three four five
different stimuli and what we look at is
basically a stimuli in action so there
are several natural actions of the
stimuli for example look at this person
who's playing a god so you see that it
moves from frame to frame as you look at
his divert so he gets up and prepares
themselves make this move pens down
launches himself into the air then dies
forward makes this move dies forward and
then lands below or look at how this
word goes and reply so these are the
ordinal positions these are the
positions in which basically the
sequence of action should go and these
are the number of actions if these
stimuli is done so what is the result of
a study like this what happens in a
study like this so in a study like this
DeRosa found that the stimuli consisted
both of as I said it consisted a number
of ordered pictures in one after another
and so the result of the study says that
if the memory set consisted of some
randomly selected subset of nine
pictures from any of the cells the
results were similar to Starbucks
results so if let's say that I give you
a number of positions to verify so what
I do is let's say from the first stimuli
here I take in ordinal positions 1 3 2 6
9 4 9 and then I ask you to verify
whether 5 is there or let's say 4 is
there in this set or not so that is what
you need to do so this is the fourth
position which is there and I have
selected the first position the third
position the fourth position obvious
the the second position then then so
this is the way in which it it is the
sixth position followed by the fourth
position and the ninth position and so
they are in an unordered list and so
you'll have to go and search whether
this is there or not so in this kind of
search when the queue has to be searched
in a display like this in a situation
like this in a feature like this then a
serial exhaustive search is what happens
here but then interestingly if an
ordered set is used so instead of using
instead of using this kind of a random
sequence if I give an ordered set so if
I take positions number 1 3 5 7 8 & 9
and if I give you to find whether 3 is
present here or not parallel search
exists so items when they are presented
randomly if the memory said if the test
item that you have to find out in the
memory set and the memory set consists
an unordered kind of a setup and another
kind of a list where all ordinary
positions are randomly mixed ordinal
positions are present then in those
cases what really happens is the search
is more or less of the type which is
popular to what Starnberg says it is
serial exhaustive search in nature but
then when if I have an ordered position
or if I have there an ordered search in
those cases so if I take 1 3 5 7 8 9 and
so it's rather 3 is present or not there
are parallel searches which results here
so that is what this says so results
were similar to Strandberg when random
selected subject was taken but when in
order substrates were taken took
participants no longer to search for
file item then it then 4 2 and so
generally there was paralyzed so this
raises suggest that SEM does treat
organized material in different form the
organized material also may be process
apparently work differently as a
function of material that has to be
remembered so basically the search is
both can be both
cereal or different different types of
searches are there but when it is
ordered material it could be cereal
exhaustive when it is not ordered maybe
it is parallel or it could be a simple
sell terminating sells such so depending
on the material which is being presented
in the CAI type of task which is there
the it is decided what kind of search
will happen now
the problem was that Sdn as we saw here
is basically then quickly define what it
is esta is basically a short term memory
esteem is a short term store which has
first of all a limited capacity so one
of the things which you should be aware
of is that it has a limited capacity and
the capacity here is 7 plus or minus 2
although ian's need came up with a new
idea that it has 4 plus or minus two
items that is what it is but will not
discuss this right now will focus on to
the original Miller's idea then it has
seven plus or minus two items to be
looked at then the second thing is the
way items are coded and so mostly a
caustic coding happens in short-term
memory the type of coding that is
happens in short-term memory or the way
items are encoded onto short-term memory
is elastic in nature it is basically in
terms of verbal and rehearsal is the
main reason for this kind of storage and
then the time period for which any item
can remain the short-term store without
being reputation is 18 to 20 second and
this is an output from the brown and
Peterson task
also the fact that forgetting mostly in
short-term memory can happen both from
decay and from interference mostly it is
interference but then we have decay also
as a reason and so mostly it is
interplay between decay
interference which lets you lose
memories from short-term store and the
last point that has to be that can we
remember here or that has any value here
is that retrieval from this kind of a
store is basically mostly in a serial
exhaustive manner so serial exhaustive
search basically a serial exhaustive way
of replacement of this particular
materials but depending on the type of
material use this serial exhaustive
search could also turn out to be
parallel exhaustive search or some other
form of such which is needed now we have
looked at what STM is and what it does
and what is the various ways in which
STM works but there was debate which was
going on within the community of
cognitive psychologists and that was
that
at times STM was somehow not approved of
what do I mean by this if you look at
the the first instance of my definition
of the short-term store I explained to
you there is something called the serial
position effect and so what we found out
in the serial position effect is it's an
effect like this so what happens is a
list of numbers are given to you a list
of items are given to you and asked to
remember then what happens is items at
the beginning of the list and items at
the end of the list are remembered more
than items at the middle of the and
those two two things are called the
primacy and recency effect now it was
found out in several experiments that if
items which had some kind of a personal
meaning to people and even if they were
presented in the middle of the list they
had a higher chance of remembering and
so this played several people or several
psychologists to go ahead and question
this idea of a single store
which doesn't do anything but stores
information for some period period of
time and no act onto it the question
this particular store so the question
was whether short-term store was a
static store or a dynamic store and a
number of questions of time also this
interference does interference
work on to all kinds of items which is
stored so if there is a visual item and
if there is an order to the item where
whether this kind of interference that
we talk about whether it happens on on
two different different modalities or
different different encodings of items
which is there
so if different versions of items are
presented or different types of items uh
presented whether this interference will
there be there or not and several
studies reported that it was not there
and so was conceived the idea of working
memory so in the coming class we look
into what is working memory and how does
is working memory concept go ahead and
take up or basically replace the concept
of short-term memory thank you
[Music]
you